[Musique]
jour un jour quand tu viendras le
minerai petit train cher au montréalais
et au Québécois qui rappelle ce bon
souvenir c'était facile de faire le tour
et je trouvais ça je trouvais ça bien
c'était là tu avais le temps d'observer
tout ça non c'était bien mais c'est
quand même des bons souvenirs
en effet vous souvenez de quoi
particulièrement dans la toute
l'ambiance de l'expo et puis de la
vision qu'on avait aussi
le plus haut que le lapin c'était très
agréable
le minéral a été installé pour l'Expo 67
c'était en fait un métro de surface qui
reliait à la cité du Havre et les
pavillons de l'île Sainte-Hélène et de
l'île Notre-Dame après l'Expo 67 et bien
le minéral est devenu une attraction de
la ronde il a circulé jusqu'en 2019 pour
être ensuite abandonné lors de la
pandémie
pour des raisons de sécurité la
direction du parc a décidé de le démolir
c'est un petit peu un
la fin de quelque chose avec la disp
ersion dernier train le minéral a été
construit en Suisse il était donc pas
neuf à l'Expo 67 il y a deux choses en
fait que l'équipe de drapeau est l'organ
isation suite à l'exposition de Lausanne
en 64 le mini rail et la spirale
technologique ça fait longtemps qu'on
qui existe donc peut-être quelque chose
de mieux aujourd'hui de plus sécuritaire
l'organisme irritage Expo 67 qui veut
préserver la mémoire du mini rail vient
de demander à l'explorat de Saint
constant le Musée ferroviaire canadien
de mettre la main sur quelques wagons
l'urgence là c'était vraiment de
préserver quelques trains avant qu'ils
partent pour la ferraille
une partie du mini rail risque donc de
se retrouver au musée histoire de nous
rappeler de bons moments ici Jacques
Bissonnière Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]